alors je vais pas se construit la caméra
2 bonjour et vos mains on a trois
caméras seulement donc cesser de se
tromper on avait 30 combien de
pourcentage d'erreurs c'est la première
question aujourd'hui l'émission
bienvenue tout le monde autour de la
planète à tam tam canada diffusée en
direct heure de montréal
11h11 35 ans maintenant on a juste un
petit peu retard 9 secondes 10 secondes
aujourd'hui parce que il y avait on se
demandait si notre invité est notre
invité mystère serait avec nous il est
au téléphone pour moment tente d'établir
la communication sur la nouvelle
technologie skype mais il n'est pas
encore rentré dans la navette spatiale
nous dit on passe alors pour devenir le
sujet de l'émission aujourd'hui il
s'agit bien sûr d'un sujet qui est caché
à nos animateurs invités il y as autour
de la table ismaël ou dassine qu'il a
pour la deuxième fois d'affilée si oui
il est là où je me situe fantastique je
suis ravi belle surprise deuxième fois
en quelques mois
c'est comme il en effet quand on sent
gagnant à deux c'est un bon début et
puis allez chantal tandem est avec nous
également
les collectes de là l'équipe française
radio canada international des fonds dit
autrefois lit que la section ça fait un
peu administratifs dont nous on est sur
le terrain et notre arbitres et ces
démissions au côté technique et bien
cegid marie claude simard bonjour marie
claude bonjour vous parler espagnol pas
du tout pas du tout il ya quelqu'un qui
parle espagnol autour de la table je
parle un peu espagnol hola vous risquez
de gagner des points aujourd'hui
alors notre jeu mystère que ce soit peu
les questions son mystère mots simples à
eau
je vois qu'on a été vidé la
communication avec nos qualités
spéciales
invité spécial bonjour monsieur je dirai
simplement votre prénom parce que je ne
veux pas qu'on vous reconnaisse nous
entendez vous nous entendez merci vous
nous entendez très bien ayant non vous
voit ses vingt sur vingt fantastique
d'accord alors je lui explique ce qui se
passe
vous restez sur la voie d'évitement an
pendant 5 minutes pendant que les
collègues ici se réveille au sujet de
l'émission et ensuite on se tourne vers
vous le spécialiste de la question qu'on
débat aujourd'hui d'accord excellent
alors maintenant que la technique tout
va bien on est prêts pour la mise à feu
allons-y
vidéo cinq images deviner tous les deux
tout les trois s'il le faut moi j'ai
vraiment pas regardé bon alors tous les
toits en vous devinez le sujet démission
aujourd'hui cinq images vous bloquez la
une à l'ena oui vous pensez que c'est
l'année non c'est le cadeau le plus gros
cargo au monde
ça pourrait être ça les accidents c'est
joyeux à l'automobile
sûr de sa libre échange qui est la
première personne qui a dit que c'était
l'alena mois fantastiques chantal c'est
le sujet c'était difficile de cacher la
marchandise qui est prête
on la livraison et puis les tarifs
automobile n'oublions pas donald trompe
avec sa menace son épée de damoclès qui
pèse sur la tête ce canadien donc
définitivement le sujet et c'est
totalement d'imagination de traiter du
sujet dans tout le monde parle depuis
deux semaines est capitale pour le
canada avant tout à fait ne peuvent se
défiler voilà donc toujours en
négociations intenses à washington j'ai
donné le titre à cette émission qui
offre vous allez voir qu'on va avoir un
aspect bien particulier nous qu'on va
développer ensemble pour décrire ses
négociations avec nos auditeurs à
travers le monde
on parle de négociations entre trois
amigos sur fond de perfidie de tromperie
et de football entre trois amigos entre
guillemets ouais mais c'est pas une
affirmation il gémit 1.2.2 question de
six fours bonne tromperie et tromperie
perfidie ben oui je voudrais faire une
affirmation je suis évidemment un jour
industriels tels faits
mervans qui étaient nos spécialistes
vous avez deviné le sujet avant d'aller
vers le spécialiste quand même quelque
chose pour comment il appelle sa
vulgarisation
je pense que certaines aux auditeurs
dans le monde ont besoin de
vulgarisation sur c'est quoi cet accord
quand
de renégocier avec des états unis du
mexique depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
alors on a je pense à vous proposer ce
que j'ai vu de meilleurs cette semaine
une vidéo faite par lacroix qui est un
organisme je pensais en france ça s'est
extrêmement bien fait en trois minutes
il expliqué tout mieux que nous
expliquer la wii lui que nous ici à rci
mais pas mieux car radio canada donc
j'ai dû mettre une croix sur la croix
mais j'ai cette vidéo d'olivier bachand
notre journaliste à radio-canada et vous
explique en moins d'une minute ce que
c'est cet accord allons cesser la vidéo
3 n'est ce pas à deux c'est beau 880
milliards de dollars en 2015 près de 9
millions d'américains doivent leur
emploi aux échanges commerciaux entre
les deux pays et le canada exporte les
trois quarts de ces marchandises chez
nos voisins du sud en 1994 année de
l'entrée en vigueur de l'accord de libre
échange nord américain
les exportations vers les etats-unis ont
atteint 183 milliards de dollars depuis
elles n'ont cessé de greffer d'année en
année son fait à deux occasions
après les attaques du 11 septembre 2001
et lors de la crise financière de 2008
2009 où une chute de plus de 100
milliards la cedh extraits puis langer a
ajouté ce graphique puisque une image
vaut mille manque surtout d'un
journaliste alors regardez ça sa sauce
et les comas l'importance du commerce
entre nos deux pays
petit shoot évidemment avec 2008 et puis
sinon c'est ça ça nous mène au premier
jeu de la grosse boule aujourd'hui c'est
bon pour dans cette première manche 20
points d'accord d'accord c'est très
facile vous allez voir je vous demandez
vous si quelqu'un parler l'espagnol et 6
passes est important vous êtes donc en
français on parle de l'alena de l'accord
de libre-échange nord-américain a en un
clin on parle du naphta
ça veut dire quoi en anglais ça n'est ce
pas c'est comment comme on dit en
espagnol l'acronyme ctl can t elle
cannes alors celui qui se rapproche le
plus de la pluie allié avec l'accent
commercial un commercial
comme quoi c'était tlc à n
c'est libre et libre et younes
commercial américain s'est pas portée
bon ben on a qui s'en rapproche le plus
alors accordé vous tous les deux 20
points bon pouvez-vous me l'a dit moi
j'ai pas l'accent donc on a demandé à
notre collègue paloma martinez qui ne
pouvais pas être avec nous aujourd'hui
micky d'origine mexicaine pour qui cette
émission est un sujet commun en or mais
elle tenait à participer voici sa
réponse
ce que ça veut dire tlc son s'il vous
plaît plus élevé le sont pour rien qu'il
faut partager ce 33e en fait un cadeau à
l'équipe et alors qu'on se tourne vers
yankees notre spécialiste aujourd'hui je
pense que souvent on ne bat quand on lui
dit bonjour on l'appelle pas yann on
l'appelle en général monsieur simon
bonjour monsieur simon bonjour comment
allez vous ça va très bien sympathique
de votre part de vous joindre à notre
équipe de personnages incompétent parce
que nous on vous pose des questions
élémentaires et c'est vous qui avez la
charge de la des explications quand vous
vous êtes professeur à la faculté des
sciences de l'administration de
l'université laval dans la ville de
québec
je pense qu'il ya aussi un acronyme
attaché à votre nom quelque part vous
n'êtes pas directement quelque chose ou
est ce si rennes le centre
interuniversitaire de recherche sur les
réseaux d'entreprise la logistique et le
transport et vous aurez compris par là
naya énormément transports bon je mange
je ne savais pas alors l'homme à poney
quelque chose je voulais savoir nous on
vous connaître les dessous cachés de ces
négociations là et je pense que là on
est on est pris dans une négociation
avec les états unis va alors c'est un
accord à trois pays et il ya il semble
qu'on a été divisé le monde divisent
pour gouverner c'est ce que monsieur
tron pas faire semble-t-il ont avec le
mexique en ayant un accord préliminaire
qui nous lie un peu les bras et les
mains ici au canada
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
mexique ben en fait avec le mexique
voulait bien diviser pour régner et on a
choisi d'avoir une négociation
bilatérale avec le mexique d'abord pour
mettre la pression avec les canada a
mais aussi pour faciliter peut-être le
compromis parce que le canada avait lui
des items de négociation sur lesquels il
ne voulait pas bouger parce et
simplement aux mécanismes de résolution
des différends pensez aussi à d'autres
bons éléments en cher aux canadiens
comme la gestion de leur type de clause
donc on pensait doté d'une qu'un qui
serait plus facile d'arracher un accord
au mexique ce qu'on a fait et dans cet
accord là avec le mexique
un accord temporaire disons le don assez
pu infiltrer paradoxalement et tout le
monde pour dire qu'il y aurait un accord
17 assez particulier parce que dans
cette négociation si on a bien vu de la
part des américains des positions très
évasive et beaucoup moins bien défini
que dans la négociation de l'alena mais
il reste qu'avec le mexique on a fait
donc des accommodements sur notamment
l'industrie automobile le pourcentage de
contenu régional donc qui passerait à
75% avec un pourcentage des véhicules
qui seraient fabriqués par de main
d'oeuvre qui serait payé plus de 16 $
l'heure et ça monsieur chambre pas rendu
des syndicats très heureux aux états
unis mais ça vient masquer quand même la
réalité des fournisseurs de cette
industrie là où même aux états unis
elle a toujours respecté disons par les
acteurs de l'industrie avec le mexique
aussi on a négocié des desclaux très
très drôle à dire que pour un canadien
c'est intéressant de savoir que le
mexique maintenant dans sa relation avec
les etats-unis une reconnaissance
formelle que la tequila est
effectivement avec 6 guen la migros
ovono je voudrais que la pierre
d'achoppement c'était bien évidemment
des questions liées à l'automobiles
admiration il ya d'autres industries
transfrontalière ils vont vous avez vu
que tout de suite après les sept accords
de principe l'âme sucre l'extradition
commence à parler de murs ce que les
mexicains ont vivement défendu parce que
la position mexicaine c'est de ne jamais
permettre un mur donc on se sert de
cette négociation là pour broder des
enjeux autour des négociations ne sont
pas que commerciaux va me connais quand
plusieurs questions à vous poser le
brûle de vous de vous mettre au pilori
mais je l'écouté le mexique est ce qui
nous a laissé tomber au canada parce
qu'on est allé au départ dans ces
négociations il ya un an ya deux ans on
avait un front commun canado mexique
puissant que l'affairé était
complètement dissoute pour le mexique
alena ne se fait pas sans le canada même
si on a négocié vie latéralement et
c'est aussi le cas pour les états unis
c'est à dire que beaucoup d'acteurs
américains et notamment au congrès ont
dit que l'alena ne se faisait pas non
plus sans canada ce qui met
l'administration de l'actuel la maison
blanche donc un peu dans l'embarras
ici la raison pour laquelle les prises
d'artyom ces derniers jours sur les
questions ni à la menace est bien la
clique et d'essayer de faire battre en
retraite le congrès or le congrès lui
assure il a la compétence pour ce type
d'accord qu'il décidera utilement le
canada doit pas être à la table
donc c'est ce qui fait que le prise d'un
job baissé lui de mettre la pression sur
le canada pour avoir un accord
rapidement possible qui pourra présenter
au congrès mais il reste que avec les
élections du mandat qui arrive et avec
le contexte vent qui change au mexique
pensez à l'élection de deux nouveaux
bras d'or quittent un peu plus à gauche
que son prédécesseur
ça viendra brouiller les cartes et c'est
la raison pour laquelle l'administration
américaine est un peu nerveux c'est sûr
nous allons parler des négociations
bilatérales entre le canada et les états
unis
on va bientôt
tam est la troisième semaine de
négociations et puis on a l'impression
que ça piétine ça n'avance pas malgré
l'optimisme affiché par la ministre des
affaires étrangères christian freeland
et à derrière des syndicats qui sont
inquiets je parlais à un représentant
des teamsters canada qui dit mais il va
falloir que le canada bouge qu'on lâche
un peu de lest con qu'on fasse des
concessions notamment en ce qui concerne
le chapitre 19 ou la gestion de l'offre
qu'en pensez vous en fait la stratégie
canadienne a été très astucieuse parce
qu'on est face à un partenaire qui ne
dévoile pas du tout son jeu le
partenaire américain lui et c'est
d'extraire des concessions à une
attitude de qui est très intransigeante
sur certains systèmes à la table le
canada lui arrive à la table sans faire
de surprise sans faire de grandes
envolées mais les intérêts des canadiens
sont très claires le mécanisme de
résolution des différends le programme
entre hugo a bien que c'était non
négociable et dans un contexte où bon on
a souvent fait l'analogie de l'éléphant
et de la souris lorsqu'on parle du
canada et des états unis
dans le contexte où il ya une asymétrie
pouvoir c'est bien d'avoir à un organe
indépendant qui puisse décider de
certains différends commerciaux parce
que sinon eh ben on va quand même style
ou l'autre option c'est d'aller vers des
instances américaines qui
traditionnellement sont beaucoup plus
favorables aux intérêts et aux
entreprises de leur pays
donc d'avoir un forum comme ça un
mécanisme de règlement des différends ça
peut être très intéressant évidemment le
canada ne veut pas plier sur la gestion
de l'offre
il y aura probablement de ce côté-là des
accommodements à des volumes admis sur
le territoire canadien sans tarifs comme
on l'a fait pour le libre échange avec
l'europe ou dans le cadre du partenariat
transpacifique à onze on a aussi négocié
donc de ce côté là on pourra peut-être
lâché un peu de lest
du côté maintenant d'aider certains
chapitres pensées vont à des trucs comme
le commerce électronique les exemptions
d'ailleurs plus de place pour négocier
le gouvernement trudeau habilement et si
on veut agité l'épouvantail culturel et
ça c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est à bien bouger un peu
la stratégie négociations notre
adversaire car il s'aperçoit qu'à maison
en avance il ya des enjeux qui arrivait
saleforce avait jeté ses positions donc
le fait que les états unis mettre la
pression
ça semble le mettre la pression sur nous
mais il reste que c'est une tactique
habituelle de la maison blanche de cette
maison de la russie qui négocie un peu
selon ses propres termes et l'attitude
canadienne elle de ne pas rentrer dans
ce jeu là je venais un tout petit peu
sur le mécanisme de résolution des
différends il comme je vous ai dit j'en
ai discuté un tout petit peu avec le
syndicat des teamsters qui pensent qu on
pourrait par exemple laisser tomber le
chapitre et 19 et porter les différents
à l'organisation mondiale du commerce
qu'en pensez vous c'est une stratégie
qui a déjà été utilisée lorsque le
mécanisme des différents donner des
réponses partielles ou en fait ne
répondait pas un jeu c'est une stratégie
qui ne fonctionnera pas dans la mesure
où la phase actuelle choisies -des aussi
de paralyser les tribunaux de l'om sait
qu on ne ment pas de juge en utilisant
des tactiques procédurales et donc ce
mécanisme cela existe dans les faits
mais malheureusement est pris en otage
mais les élections de mi-mandat aux
etats-unis est-ce que c'est une
opportunité ou un piège pour le canada
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
états unis et en particulier la maison
blanche et sur l'administration met la
pression sur le gouvernement trudeau
pour arriver à un accord le plus
rapidement possible mais d'un autre côté
j'ai aussi l'impression que le
gouvernement trudeau ne prend pas
l'opportunité des élections de mi-mandat
pour aussi mettre sur la table ces
conditions qu'est ce que vous en pensez
façades pourtant très attention de ne
pas s'immiscer dans les élections d'un
pays ami
il n'est pas bien vu aux états unis
connaissant deux enquêtes parallèles
attention les précédents assez
habile cette fois ci dans cette ronde là
parce qu'on en a fait une stratégie de
relations publiques auprès des états où
le canada est un partenaire commercial
majeur les grandes qualités aussi ont
reçu des visites de sienne canadien au
cours des derniers mois on réalise enfin
du côté canadien qui aux états unis la
police ne se situe pas 40 à washington
mais qu aux etats unis comme vous êtes
et fournir par effet que c'est son corps
et donc ça fait qu'il ya quand même une
opinion très favorable pour le canada
dans ces négociations la dena partie
simplement l'état du minnesota qui dont
le gouverneur et beaucoup d'officiels
ont publiquement supporter la résolution
rapide d'un an à l'ena qui leur
semblerait peut-être à l'alena qu'on
connaît mais un peu modernisé l'anc
de ce côté là il ya quand même un
mouvement très intéressant qui
soutiennent canada c'est pas une panacée
je vous dirai pas ce qu'elle est on
négocie avec le fédéral aux états unis a
mis le fait d'avoir les états profit
c'est quand même un gros plus c'est
sacha qu'il ya des élections au poste de
gouverneur aussi ça peut être un atout
pour la suite mais c'est a choisi lady
quand même parce que on a l'impression
que les dirigeants en particulier le
président des états unis règle ses
comptes il ya beaucoup de psychologie de
deggo de relation de personne on n'est
plus là dans des temps des pourparlers
un peu saine et normale de da traité on
est là vraiment aussi parfois on a
l'impression de voir des des chicanes
entre des dirigeants puis à beaucoup de
dégoût et de personnalités de la part de
l'administration américaine est ce que
ça s'éteint c'est un fossé c'est un mur
caractéristiques actuelles
merci à celui qui était aussi
précédemment acquis et un nationaliste
économiques américains reconnus et qui
essaie de composer avec disons les
sautes d'humeur que les variations
politique de son administration
tout en ayant une position consistante à
la table de négociations donc faut
reconnaître que son travail n'est pas
facile mais il faut aussi reconnaître
comme canadienne de travail c'est pas de
facilités mission
donc il ya un équilibre un peu délicat
ici mais le disons qu'il est plus utile
à long terme d'essayer de négocier avec
la machine entre guillemets que de
négocier dans les médias avec des
politiciens qui on a l'eau dans des
envolées verbales vous des envolées
twitter est ce qui est ce qu'il ya
dedans quand on parle des comportements
de certains politiciens
est ce qu'il y mensonge des choses qui
ont été dites qui finalement ne font pas
avancer la cause de ceux qui veulent
négocier avec force et dynamisme en les
pressant de mensonges vous appartient
exemple il ya des inexactitudes
volontaires qui ont été formulées
surtout du côté américain par exemple
sur la question des déficits commerciaux
avec les canada ou sur la question des
industries qui perdait dans la relation
et canada qui est totalement faux
est ce que les données économiques
américaines officiel le montre tout le
monde a gagné à l'alena et c'est un très
très bon accord et même l'année n'a
permis une intégration supplémentaires
de nos trois pays qui nous a permis
qu'on crée notamment l'asie et l'europe
de l'est
plusieurs streaming certains autres
géographie donc la ligne est un facteur
de compétitivité il faut faire très
attention de ne pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain dans cette renégociation
là je dirais que la bonne nouvelle c'est
que les chapitres qui était saison des
accords parallèles notamment son
environnement travail risquent de
devenir des chapitres officielle de
l'accord donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant en modernisant belle on va
parler de commerce électronique qui on
va parler un peu de droits des
travailleurs ce genre dit hemlock ne
sont pas d'habitude dans des accords de
libre échange
donc là il ya quelque chose pour les
grands syndicats américains mexicains ou
canadiens il ya un peu aussi de
dépoussiérage à faire sur le plan de ce
qui doit ou non remplis en franchise de
nos exemption à nouveau hier comme
canadien lorsqu'on passe la frontière et
celle des amis m6 est toute la question
de la réglementation des migrations
parce que maintenant il ya des statuts
très intéressant
de visa qui permettent à des
travailleurs temporaires de bienvenue
entre les trois pays il faudrait pas
perdre les avantages sont liés à ce
statut leur nom une dernière question
ah oui une dernière question on a
souvent entendu le premier ministre
justin trudeau dire qu'il vaudrait mieux
pour le canada ne pas avoir d'accord du
tout que de conclure un mauvais accord
qu'adviendrait-il si jamais le canada et
les états unis ne s'entendaient pas
est-ce qu'on pourrait envisager
je sais pas moi un accord bilatéral
canada mexique ou bien pas d'accord du
tout avec les états unis
ben on a déjà un accord avec le mexique
sous forme du partenaire quand tu passes
tes couleurs il ya déjà un cadre
beaucoup plus restrictif par ailleurs
que celui qui est prévu par l'alena
actuelle qui est en force donc ce côté
ne serait un peu couvert
ça ne nous empêche pas d'avoir des
accords pussy plus de façon bilatérale
et les volumes commerciaux au niveau
sans qu'on les etats-unis ou l'europe
ward quoi avec d'autres géographies
faisons le si vous regardez maintenant
toute la question est ce que on peut
trouver d'autres manières d'être plus
créatifs dans ce type de négociations la
bad à l'ena serait pas une catastrophe
mais ce serait un point du maquereau pas
très intéressant il y aurait beaucoup
d'industries qui perdrait et certaines
industries qui pourraient se réajuster
mais la position préférée c'est celle
d'avoir un aréna pour permettre aux
entreprises qui veulent se prévaloir
d'un tel accord 2 si on veut la
suppression de droits de douane puisse
s'en privent s'en prévaloir
oui l'om c'est le fonctionnaire est là
pour faire du commerce ou les risques de
l'om 6 mai les tarifs seraient un peu
plus et nous paie et ça rendrait
certains de nous un peu moins
concurrentielles sur le plan mondial
mais je on ne fermerait pas les lumières
après l'abandon de l'alena et puis après
l'abordage madonna ya l'autre débat
est-ce que la fin de la liga à vous dire
le retour à l'aller original puisque
certains juristes croix mr probablement
pas le cas parce que l'administration
trump le risque de l'imi mais celui là
quand on s'apercevra dakar est donc là
il ya un jeu politique est aussi un jeu
constitutionnel internes aux états unis
qui aura raison entre
exécutif et le législatif et donc le
rôle de ce congrès de renégociation
leurs aidants ok dans la progression
dans l'abrogation de ce type d'accord
donc il ya dix ans c'était une boîte de
pandore ce jeu faudrait pas tellement
ouvrir dans le camp souhaite bien
d'accord écoutez monsieur simon on
pourrait poursuivre la conversation puis
de fait il ya d'autres questions qui est
sûre chez semaine évidemment nous on a
un contrat avec les états unis on peut
pas dépasser 30 minutes d'entrevue un
plaisir de vous recevoir à l'émission et
en plus de ça moi je ressors de cette
conversation en étant plus optimistes
moins stressé pourquoi oui les choses se
ressemblent plus le plus sain plus
limpide 1
malgré ce qu'on ressent dans les
journaux dans les médias depuis deux
trois quatre semaines
c'est l'impression que le canada est sur
la sur le faire où je brûle entre merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé aujourd'hui
journée c'est yan cimon professeur à la
faculté des sciences d'administration à
l'université laval et on lui parlait
alors qu'il se trouve à houston au
centre pour la navette spatiale
non sérieusement vous faites quelque
chose sur l'astronaute sur la place trop
noté david saint jacques
il va s'envoler bientôt pour la station
spatiale internationale à bord à bord de
la fusée soyouz
j'avais entendu parler de soyouz la
semaine dernière avec cet incident un
problème
oui avec se trouve être une catastrophe
mais ça aurait pu être une catastrophe
il ya eu plus de peur que de mal parce
qu'en fin de compte les astronomes qui
étaient tous sains et saufs
ce qui est bien dans l'espace et que
pour maintenir la pression risation
dallaire à l'abord vraiment besoin d'une
très forte pression
c'est pas comme si vous étiez sous la
mer sous l'océan indien peu de pression
puisque le nom mais c'est que c'était
juste un tout petit trou qui a été
atteint la brèche a été tout de suite
colmatée par un spécialiste russe qui se
trouvaient à bord de soyouz le pire a
été évité mais oui bien et éviter cela
va faire un bon film sauf que maintenant
on veut savoir ce qu'il
est ce que c'était un accident est ce
que c'était volontaire s'est jusque là
on sait pas encore c'est qu'il ya eu un
trou sur terre d'être au moment de la
fabrication du soyouz
mais on ne sait pas qui l'a fait dont on
cherche à établir les responsabilités
moi c'est un trou magnifique qu'ils
étaient à l'origine du trou dans twin
arrivée n'a rien à voir là pas encore
tweeté la nasa n'ont plus la nasa ne
s'est pas prononcé pour normal enquête
se poursuit du côté russe on parle de ça
c'est un vote sujet aujourd'hui vendredi
mais alors que l'émission est diffusée
en direct de montréal
on pourrait aller sur la page technique
de radio canada tam tam et s'arrête sur
le web pour à partir de midi 12h15 il
tout le monde va pouvoir poursuivre la
conversation sur la sphère de l'aréna
avec nos articles récents là dessus je
pense qu'on a aligné six ou 5 1 quand on
continue et descendez la pin up ça y va
découvrez nos archives et vous allez
vous reconnaitre ici un studio à l'iss
ismaël vous avez écrit certains c'est le
canada peut-il se passer de l'alena
c'est la réponse s'est rapidement que le
choléra si oui et non bon c'est maryse
et vous stéphane non je pense que vous
avez fait quelque chose quelque chose
là-dessus temps on voit pas de
compromission chapitre 19 places et vous
stéphane uni der et les producteurs
laitiers c'est encore vous ah bon
marie-claude apprend d'équilibrer
davantage
[Rires]
justement s'impose je pense qu'il doit y
avoir erreur quelque part avoir écouté
ça c'est pour ceux qui veulent
poursuivre la conversation se faire chez
nous en studio on poursuit notre test de
connaissance générale de nos collègues
et on est prêt pour la deuxième manche
le jeu de la grosse boule pourquoi c'est
comme quand j'étais à l'école moi les
appelait les tests avec le vendredi
alors plutôt d'arriver à l'école d'être
l'axé vendredi des journées à prescrire
alors écoutez pour être pour la deuxième
jeu c'est très facile encore une fois la
réponse c'est facile si vous avez des
connaissances générales l'année n'a elle
résulte de l'extension d'un accord
précédent qui ne concernait que le
canada et les états unis qu'on appelait
l'accord de libre échange canado
américain d'accord il à l'ena a repris
un certain nombre de principes et la
corde les lainages ou donne du
background a été signé le 17 décembre
1992 et est entré en vigueur en 94 donc
ils ont mis deux ans à mettre son élan
vigueur bon nous on veut savoir la chose
suivante qui étaient les chefs d'état au
mexique au canada et aux états unis
en 92 lors de la signature de l'accord
originel de l'alena mais c'était en 94
c'est l'accord assignant 92 et mise en
vigueur en 84 oui à tout faire 94 c'est
à melbourne et ouais mais on nous on
veut savoir à 92 pour le canada ce qui
ad'autres de bouder d'autre choix
possible peut-être davantage
moi j'ai toujours pour sa monnaie quand
je pense à l'alena je pense à mon rôle
avez vous déjà voté aux élections aux
états unis c'était bouche en bouche
crise cette année oui c'est vrai bush
père et bush fils 192 but c'était en
oui bouge pas elle est en 2007 et bush
fils avait que moi je me suis quand même
ma bouche mais que les attentats étaient
bouche
oui le grand 93
92 c'était bouge pas je bouge pas par
tafer carrière très bien donc on a été
dit c'est pas mal vous avez tous 30
points pour le moment mais mais c'est la
personne qui va vraiment avoir 30 points
ce qui nous inquiétait le président
mexicain
le président mexicain ouais côté qu'une
des mois les mois je vais vous accordez
eu le don va simplifier les choses
le nom du président commence par quelle
lettre de l'alphabet celui qui se trouve
le plus proche grand porteur non mais
étant donné qu'on sait même pas déjà
c'était qui vous diriez vous comme dans
les allées mais en plus j'ai pas la
réponse je n'avais pas la réponse avant
de préparer cette question j'ai été
trouvé la réponse
et c'est pas l'homme à martinez qui m'a
donné la réponse cette vidéo pour vous
en écoute
non je passais la numéro 5 du traité de
libre échange était lé président
américain george w.bush travaux les
premiers ministres canadien et le
président mexicain carlos salinas de
gortari carlos salinas de gortari
s'agisse gortat lors cdd n'ont pas
essayé j'ai essayé moi j'ai 10e mais
venté 50 points bravo et on en passe
c'est tellement de pression c'était bush
père et bush père en 80 ans wayne rooney
84e va là je vais vous présenter l'avis
du numéro 6 oui il s'agit de paloma mais
c'est pas elle pas une réponse à une
question elle a fait une entrevue avec
un spécialiste sur la question du
mexique et
l'entrevue en espagnol ou en français en
français enfin imaginer alors j'ai
découvert ça dans les archives
n'allez pas trop vite parce qu'il faut
que je trouve le nom de son invité c'est
la vidéo au numéro 6 alors est ce que
c'est parce que c'est pas écrit sur
votre programme d'ethnique planète
c'est difficile à trouver à la vitesse
j'ai tellement de choses écrites ici
alors écoutez toujours en coupe daniel
choix d'un président à la recherche de
l'institut indépendant de recherche
oui bon d'accord en entrevue effectuée
au mois de juillet et il le disait que à
part ce qui est discuté à l'alena dans
l'accord et que mes propres ailes et
beaucoup plus loin il faudrait aller
beaucoup plus loin
voici un extrait exemple quand on
regarde l'accord en tant qu'un des deux
chili il ya toute une section de cet
accord-là qui tourne autour de l'impact
de commerce pourrait avoir sur sur
l'égalité entre entre les ex par exemple
il ya dans l'accord avec l'union
européenne
qu'on a présentement il ya tout un
mécanisme pour vérifier que un mécanisme
plus fort que celui de l'alena pour
vérifier que les parties prennent en
compte si on veut les
les droits du travail même l'impact que
d'accord au resto des travailleurs ainsi
que sur sur l'environnement dans
l'accord trans pacifique
vous avez des provisions de cet accord
là qui permettent aux parties de retirer
des concessions savait de
heureusement faire remonter les tarifs
douaniers envers des partis qui ne
respecteraient pas des droits du travail
chez eux ce qui n'est pas le cas dans la
vienne a donc dans plusieurs accords
vous avez quand même des qui existe déjà
vous avez des éléments qu'on appelle
éléments progressistes qui sont plus
forts que ceux dans l'alena
non maintenant on est en train de
renégocier l'alena avec comédie le
rapport une partie qui sont moins
intéressés à promouvoir ces droits là au
moins dix ans à l'intérieur d'accords
commerciaux
alors là c'est un extrait c'est la suite
est disponible sur les articles sur
dalena qu on vous montrait il ya
quelques instants c'est là-dessus
d'intéressant alors cette année schwahn
vice président à la recherche de
l'institut indépendant de recherche
s'est dit ah donc un organisme qui se
trouve la côte ouest canadienne
vous n'êtes pas le dernier jeu je la
voulais s'essouffler un peu parce que je
les aime aussi renvoyé beaucoup
d'épreuves cette semaine voici c'est
assez facile encore une fois c'est vous
pourriez si elle a 50 points ça pour est
ex-aequo avec vous ce point peut faire
la différence et vous vous auriez 50
points vous seriez le grand gagnant a
donc c'est la question la question la
question qui tue la question qui
assassine mais moi je trouve ça très
belle question a coûté lançant des
exportations s'exporta question des
exportations
je veux éviter de préambule vrai ou faux
le projet d'une monnaie commune au
canada etats unis mexique déjà été
abordé officiellement lors des
négociations
de l'ena en 90 ou rouge là moi j'y
arriverai
le projet d'une monnaie qu'on dit
monnaie commune oui le peso ce canadien
ça se fait aborder ne veut pas dire
sinon on n'en parlait pas mais bon ils
en ont parlé dans la presse américain
new way moi je dis oui ou non pas oui
c'est évident qu'un en parle avec l'euro
en europe en plus à être à la mode à
cette époque le monde mais oui oui bon
pense rien mais je pense pas tomber dans
le piège
je répondis je pense pas que vous soyez
tendance est à des troubles
moi j'avais pas l'intention de dire oui
justement ah non crois moi je suis je
pas pourquoi moi je le dis parce que
j'ai lu pas mal sur la nasl mais je ne
me souviens pas avoir vu une discussion
concernant la monnaie commune
je sais elle a pris son temps réfléchi
je pense qu'on est d'accord que s'il
n'avait pas eu spécialistes alors été la
spéciale je crois aussi spécialiste
alors la réponse que non ça peut être
abordé la seule fois où c'était à bord
17 en 2007 vicente fox bonne ont hissé
les idents il avait dit vous on devra
parler mais c'est en 2007 n'est jamais
auparavant on en a parlé seulement
seuls les mexicains auraient voulu en
parler parce que serez vite et certains
troubles économiques et comment on
aurait sept modèles en 2007
aucune des brisants non pas parler
suffisamment peut-être le dollar non
américain le peso
je crois que oui c'est le one non le
duan c'est au japon que l'oeil et de
spleen au japon par dont le rouble se
trompent pas et votre problème
d'accord excellent bah écoute et se fait
un plaisir de vous recevoir et partager
je pense qu'on a une grande gagnante
semblait tout à fait juste une gagnant
non avec un homme
je suis une simple gagnante aujourd'hui
entre guillemets parce que la dernière
question ben oui on peut on peut
débattre là dessus
le su finir non gagné on a participé on
a appris des choses c'est surtout ça qui
est important c'est vraiment appris des
choses oui moi j'ai bon ismaël merci
beaucoup d'être venu cette semaine
merci beaucoup marie-claude merci
beaucoup également merci et puis ali
chantal avoue également que la paix soit
avec vous on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine le 13 pris la semaine
prochaine